[Applause]
the magical good news snowflake that you
catch on your
tongue and with me at the desk is my
little snow angel rossi ross
oh my god
aren't those the best the best they
really are all right well let's get into
some even better news first up we've got
the perfect couch wear collection for
your next big streaming
binge
apartment therapy reports that netflix
has partnered with
unhide to create a cozy line of throw
blankets robes and ponchos they're 100
cruelty free and made from leftover
fabrics ooh upcycle and you can slide
from netflix and chill
right into netflix and fall asleep on
the couch oh wow
hi chill
do you
ha clap of hands how many people know
what chill means yeah you were all
yes
okay yeah i didn't know you didn't know
no because does anyone clap of hands
remember chill in the 80s and 90s was
like relax
yeah like
i i like i wanted netflix and chill but
no i want to chill the 90s style which
is just like to relax and it was like be
mellow man chill well okay so at the
beginning of a relationship you netflix
and chill and then
then you just chill you know
you netflix and uh couch potato exactly
just you just binge but just on 90 day
fiance that's what you do
but i think people will you know
definitely be excited for these blankies
oh they're going chill all right
we see you
uh you know we love a really good
holiday dinner debate and we've got a
hot one fresh out of the oven and it
comes from jolly old england except in
this case hold the jolly the mir reports
a woman says her brother-in-law and
sister-in-law are hosting christmas
dinner and they're charging a cover to
come
yes even family she says this woman says
that she personally has hosted christmas
dinner in the past she would never
charge a cover she offered she said i'll
bring a meal but they said they wanted
cold hard cash
what yes and this woman's husband sides
with the relatives what yes wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
i i'm a little confused they want to
charge someone for coming over for a
holiday that's exactly what they want to
do
why can't we just kick it old school
into a potluck girl why are you because
what are you going to have a bouncer
next to the jello mold to make sure that
i didn't
i mean does anyone think this is a good
idea
i would kind of like this gets me all
this really ruffles my feathers rossi i
don't like it
i i i
oh
i know what would you say i would just
be like well i'll be at home i'll zoom
in do you charge for
that i think it would bring out my
rebellious side totally i think i'd be
like really
you want to charge me
and then i would say a bunch of things i
can't say right now
you know what i do i host my own and say
everyone come to mind it's free yeah
exactly
well next we have a man who was no match
for his local buffet's all-you-can-eat
offer rossi you love a buffet i love a
buffet and i feel very strongly about
this story okay so food and wine reports
a live streamer in china known as mr
kang is no longer welcome at haddandi
seafood and barbecue buffet because he
eats too much the restaurant owner says
he loses money every time mr king walks
in the door i wonder if mr kang went to
one of these family's parties and now
that's why they're charging
okay so how much food are we talking
here one time he ate eight pounds of
prawn which is approximately 300 prawns
by our rough prawn math you know prawn
math it's sweeping the nation
i mean
all you can eat is a dare
what do you think rossi well i wha
listen to me sir i will represent you in
court pro bono okay
all you can eat means all you can eat
okay i will approach the bench for you
this i
tell my dying day i will fight for this
buffets mean buffet for a reason you
understand
so
don't comment me don't tell me
oh you know it gets me heated i never
get this upset about this but you tell
me all i can eat
challenge accepted
well it isn't all you can eat until i
say so
yeah that sign is too long it's nice
it means all you can eat i'm doing it
all right next we got a fuzzy wuzzy
fashion trend this season in style
reports the faux bucket hat aka the
muppet hat do you know this well it's
showing up on heads everywhere no check
out bella hadid muppeting around new
york city um what do you think drew with
us well i said no because i just didn't
like the trend in the first place but
now seeing it on these girls i i really
like it so
i guess you know a picture can change
your mind can you
see i don't look good
i guess we're not bella hadid ross
why do i look like a gay mushroom
why do i look like um
an 80s like
rejected
i don't know who am i trying to think of
yeah you see the thing is you kind of
look cute in yours sarah i look like i'm
on mario brothers
i feel like i'm like a rejected kid in
the fat albert gang
like this just doesn't work
um all right all right no
no can i see yours because it matches my
outfit maybe that's the problem well
here's the thing i mean does anyone like
these hats
no no
no
it wasn't the color it wasn't the color
you just turned into like a blues clues
character oh my god
come on kids
[Music]